on the shot clock here's that first Trey
young find of the night when that's that
bread-and-butter play we were talking
about Trey young and John collars able
to hook up once again great looks at it
V kicks it out clutter will take the
three and make the three
and prey young off to an audacious start
nine points for Dodge
zyre Smith is checked in hurt her on the
drive nicely done by Kevin in the
opening period the rookie from Virginia
trying it knocked away Isiah Smith now
Simmons comes out to challenge tre
dodges a couple of defenders camp fires
and hits 14 first quarter points for
Simmons his season-high is 24 and Tre
down the pipe to Collins amazing
productivity for tre he's had a hand in
every basket and another putter with the
jam
here's his court vision which is just
ungodly way that's a pretty easy pass
there for Trey young when you a good
point guard a good passing point guard
just don't have a ton of scoring options
out there right now Simmons pass take it
away by Craig Young great looks great
boobs in Gibbs layin hotter good this is
Trey's tenth assists as he finds hunter
on a beautiful feed no looks at right to
his teammate go tough shot for the sixes
what the Hawks defense has been pretty
good zig zags his way in lays it up and
Jones slams it home hot Jones his first
Jones just goes up over everybody and
beat didn't even try to challenge really
weird shot we're done yeah they wouldn't
had didn't have any balance even hurt
her good with the corner three for a
circle shoots over no he lobs it to
Jones today one emptied to say it looks
at and say that the sixes haven't had
some nice looks Bible defending
wraparound to Collins and one
sixes and a 76 is a pretty good
defensive team but tonight so far they
have tray inside and it's the andre
hunter that third period tray was old
for two for the field Hawk shot 33%
trach goes in on Simmons meats help
finds it in Hunter Scott right there but
hunter scores on Oh 894 Atlanta 8:10 to
play tre lobs it Jones goes gets in my
Jones go straight down the lane he goes
upstairs
nobody's gonna challenge him now mbita's
trapping and they trap the whole game
might be a little late radish for three
that's a big three right there for camp